hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be checking out the trailer for we
are your friends
starring Zac Efron and wes Bentley I saw
the first trailer movie looks okay I
didn't do a reaction to it cuz I caught
it in the theaters first so it wouldn't
be a reaction cuz this [ __ ] has to be
genuine [ __ ] five four three
two one
my friends and I we're from the San
Fernando Valley that flat stretch of
land on the other side of the Hollywood
Hills
but with actors waiters and wannabes who
came afford to live in Los Angeles
Young's life we're gonna be out of
Valley by the end of the summer look I
have an idea
this is gonna be the best the best night
of your life I'm DJing hard sucks
Elle is dead can't play drunk in love
absolutely not
we gotta get out of here yeah babe sup
in here today that's half the battle
James to see really talented sounds have
soul building from scratch you're not
gonna get anywhere using the same old
sounds at every other laptop DJ whenever
you guys are ready to start making some
real loot you know holler at me on a
regular saying don't you feel like
there's a lot more quality stuff we
could be doing when we signed up for
left them in real estate you're not
happy
in your lives they're gonna be seeing so
finishing will be tempting you can do
about it I think I'm going back to work
for that guy you're out of your mind
what happened to loyalty that you leave
here to take your crap anymore
any successful that is wrong they
stopped being an admirer in the finest
signature
I think I have something
hell's plane right now thank you
something else started playing in the
middle of that trailer Zac Efron I think
the dudes earned a lot more respect over
the years you know what I think really
changed for him it was when he did
neighbors because I think seeing him in
such a raunchy comedy and really commit
to it was something that really allowed
us to get a different image of this guy
I know he's done some dramas Rey didn't
do too bad in them but that was the
movie for me at least I like the songs
in the trailer I like listening to DJ's
didi you know there's this a really
funny sketch on it from those digital
shorts and Andy Samberg was on something
about like let the bass drop you guys
gotta find that sketch it's so [ __ ]
funny in it it's a great parody of how
that [ __ ] goes down but what I like more
about this trailer than the last one was
they really did explore more of the DJ
world and exploring details of that cuz
the first trailer it was like trying to
be a mix of that plus all this other
heavy drama stuff I liked how most of
this trailer showed us that and I'm
hoping most of the movie is that and not
that's other side drama stuff because
honestly I believe you need character
and you need more than just a DJ stuff
but the way the drama has been looking
from the last two trailers it looks kind
of cheesy it feels a little forced
everything else from that the style
looks cool zac efron looks good the
dramatic side what's appealing to me is
Jon Bernthal but the music sounds really
cool you know I want the list of songs
like honestly the soundtrack is a little
bit more appealing to me than the actual
movie itself but I feel like the DJ
stuff is gonna be cool I feel like this
stuff I want to go there and get I will
get it I feel like I'll probably be able
to overlook the dramatic stuff or at
least just accept it as a thing I don't
really care for but who knows it
actually might be good this is just a
trailer after all anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe to the reel
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope because
if we get more followers we can get even
more piranha placement
Jesse Carillo can I please get a shout
out bro my YouTube is nhw wrestling hoho
let's let's see what nhw wrestling is
all about all right you got 203
subscribers not bad not bad so it looks
like you you fight on a trampoline
that's really cool you look young I'm
gonna let you in on something you have
an opportunity here as a pitch you know
you're wrestling with dudes you can say
hey lady I have a channel you know 200
people follow me goes up a little bit
each day I do this wrestling thing and
I'd love to feature you on there to get
you some exposure yeah and then you
wrestle with her and then you lose your
virginity to her because it looks like
you're still a virgin
but I won't go there too far just know
that it could accidently happen because
I know what it's like to be your age I
was a horny little [ __ ]